newly revealed documents show a trump
organization lawyer helped with efforts
to silence adult film store film star
stormy Daniels is her name Daniels says
that she was paid one hundred and thirty
thousand dollars by mr. Trump's personal
lawyer that's Michael Cohen to stay
quiet about an alleged affair with the
president Cohen says he paid the money
without the knowledge of President or
the Trump Organization chip Reid is in
Washington with a document revealing the
possible role of another lawyer in this
story chip good morning well good
morning here's that document you just
talked about it was given to us by the
attorney for stormy Daniels it's a
demand for arbitration filed by Michael
Cohen's holding company three weeks ago
and under nature of dispute it says
breach of contract and here's the key
thing it lists Jill Martin as the
attorney for Cohen's company but Jill
Martin is also an attorney who has been
with the Trump Organization since 2010
as a vice president and assistant
general counsel the Trump Organization
has said in a statement that Martin was
working in an individual capacity and
the company has no involvement in the
matter but the fact that a lawyer for
the Trump Organization is involved
raises questions about Cohen's claim
that he acted alone to pay Daniels the
White House says President Trump denies
having an affair with Daniels at all
Nora
all right Jeff thank you so much